what are you making the micro dosing
phenomenon me this is pretty astounding
to see this bunch of [ __ ] you're
scared jump all the way and that's why
you want to medicate every day no I'm
just joking around I think I know people
who have experienced some pretty severe
benefits of it especially people that
weren't doing so good health-wise yeah
and you know we're just really kind of
feeling down and depressed Alison the
outlook radically changed particularly
psilocybin micro dosing I know a lot of
you that we're doing that yeah same I
have a lot of hope that Oregon becomes
the first state to sounds like it's
closed
yeah to legalize psilocybin that'd be a
big one it would be gigantic and I think
once we realized that no one's dying and
a lot of people are getting helped and a
lot of people that are terminal you know
are having some really amazing
alleviation of anxiety and an
understanding that it's going to be okay
and just I think between friends and
just that just the camaraderie it sort
of when you have these group experiences
together like there's some incredible
benefits to that in terms of like
reinforcing community and civilization
the way we feel about each other now
aside from the psychological and
emotional benefits I think you would be
fascinated by some of the things that
I've observed and written about of real
physical benefits of psychedelics and
I'll just tell you a couple I when I was
in my late 20s I did a lot of
experiments was in the 70s with LSD
mostly with LSD
I had a lifelong allergy to cats if a
cat got near me my eyes would itch my
nose would lawn if a cat licked me I'd
get highs or it licked me so I always
you know avoided them and didn't let him
touch me so I took LSD with a group of
friends on the Springdale ouya Virginia
fabulous you know I was outside running
around having a lot of fun and in the
middle of the cat jumped into my lap and
I had a moment of like trying to defend
myself and I thought this is silly you
know and I relaxed played with the cat
had no allergic reaction and never did
ever after instant disappearance of an
allergy that had been there all my life
well
be the physiological mechanism for
something well clearly that's a very
profound mind-body interaction now we
know that allergies are influenced by
that because you can show a person
allergic to roses a plastic rose and
they'll have an allergy so this so
there's a learned component to allergy
that can be unlearned but instead of
yeah interesting now all right this is
even more dramatic maybe a year later
same thing it was LSD in the spring I
had also grown up with a very fair skin
and was told I couldn't get tan and we
used to go down to the Jersey Shore I
can't remember I remember innumerable
times you know gets getting
second-degree burns sheets of skin
peeling off Noxzema at night we didn't
have sunscreen in those days right so I
just accepted that's how I was you know
I can't get tan so again high on LSD
lying out naked in my great woods in my
home in Virginia and the Sun was up
there and I thought this is ridiculous
you know I should not be afraid of the
Sun the next day I got tan and I have
ever since well that's it a little more
and I'm not quite sure the mechanism
there but it's pretty amazing when
you're outside for though because if
you're gonna get burnt I was out in good
time you know I would I wouldn't
normally have yeah at least I would have
had my usual reaction but my skin got
tan had never had in my life so what do
you suggest he happened again you know
there must be a way in which the nervous
system influences melanocytes which are
the you know the cell the pigment cells
in the body that can either extend their
you know projections with pigment
granules so the nervous system controls
that in the mind connects the nervous
system but what about someone who's like
ridiculously fair like what about
someone who lives in Scotland well see
what I would do is in when dr. wild
psychedelic clinic opens I would have
like an open well we'll see but there'll
be an allergy program right you go in on
the first day you take a full dose of
something and you're exposed to the
allergen and you know magic happens and
then you come in for 10 sessions with a
decreasing dose and at some point you're
not getting you're just getting a
placebo and you don't know when that is
and people are trained to lose their
allergies I hear you do the same thing
with Sun Tanning maybe not with people
from Scotland because they've got fewer
pigments
but I wouldn't roll it out I'll tell you
one more okay I'm also from this period
I told you I was playing with yoga there
was one posture I couldn't do the plow
were you lying your back and try to
touch your toes behind your head yeah I
got to where I could get my toes to a
foot from the floor and I had
excruciating pain in my neck and I as
much as I tried that I made no progress
so I was on the verge of giving up I
thought I was too old was twenty eight
so again on an LSD state my body was
feeling totally elastic I started to try
that so I'm lowering my feet I thought I
had a foot to go and they touched the
ground I couldn't believe it I raised it
lowered oh wow fantastic the next day I
tried to do it I got within a foot of
the ground had excruciating pain in my
neck but now I knew it was possible
before that I didn't it was possible so
knowing it was possible I was motivated
to keep at it and in a few weeks I was
able to do it if I had not had that
experience I would have given up so I
think this is the magic of these things
they can show you possibilities they
don't necessarily teach you how to how
to maintain them but they can show you
the things are possible you'd never
believe what didn't even seem like it
was just showing you a possibility it
was actually showing a capability yes
you were capable of moving in a way that
you didn't think you were exactly for
right and it was because of your own
tension and worry and probably learned
patterns of tension that had built up on
my life and maybe some because of the
conscious or the psychedelic state
rather there's some alleviation of
tension my mind was out of the way yeah